this week I think that my dad was just
really hard to hide [ __ ] her dad very
hard to penetrate you know he was six
four he was about 220 he's a big big man
big big voice can I ask you a question
that's an inch and this is a bizarre
question you might have to cut this out
but let's say like a 6 foot 8 guy has a
tight [ __ ] right for a 6 foot 8 wait
why would is there a stereotype to pay
yeah
no but just listen we're trying to say
basically is that typically tall people
have loose [ __ ] no that's not what
I'm saying I'm just saying let's say
that my name is Billy Billy Joe
my name is Billy Joe six eight I I hope
in Alabama right yeah and you know I
wake up one morning and I bend over in
front of a mirror and I say to myself
Wow for a six foot eight guy I sure do
have a tight [ __ ] right but to a five
foot two guy it's probably not that
tight why because he's bigger what its
perspective fakeness of an [ __ ] has
nothing to do with the size of the
[ __ ] so you're saying like Peter
Dinklage you Brad Williams all have
loose [ __ ] no no we have even
tighter hide okay why does the
perspective of sighs no no tightness has
nothing to do with bigness babe that's
just like saying hang on one second get
look you think that a bigger woman is
going to have a looser vagina no a
bigger woman could have a tight vagina
for being that size but but a smaller
I'm going to say think you're really on
to something
yeah other times I think that like
you're having a stroke
no that's why I said to cut it out I'm
just like I like to throw things out
there right and now that I realize I
don't even know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about guys
no millimeter open tight [ __ ] for
being tall but in the perspective of a
smaller person it's still loose opening
is like on a smaller person the opening
is small and then you enlarge the person
cars do all cars have to share the same
tire like for instance if I know if I
had a Hummer right yeah and then I also
had a smart car could I use the Smart
car tires onto the Hummer no why because
it doesn't fit it doesn't fit you're
right okay okay sizes Gilbert this is
what he's saying he's saying this is
actually not about [ __ ] it's about
dick size situations - how they fit into
a giant [ __ ] that makes more sense
that makes more sense that you say that
yeah small a small dick might might feel
might feel like a big [ __ ] feels
loose because of the small dick but
really that's what you're saying babe
seeing things in size big of pinkies
I'm so confused you guys I'll give an
example
all right I'll give you an example right
look at Peter did Peter Peter Dinklage's
hand right yeah it's a small beautiful
hand smaller hand let's just say it's a
theatrical dramatic hand very because
this good it does this good insane star
meter right and if Peter Dinklage stuck
his pinkie in his own [ __ ] right yes
he has a very tight [ __ ] right he be
like oh my [ __ ] yeah my ass was pretty
tight but then if he went to Andre the
Giant's [ __ ] it stuck his pinky in
andra des jahres [ __ ] it probably is
a little looser because under John's so
big I'd like to rebuttal here's
everybody looking me I rebuttal yeah yes
sweetie do you know
what an [ __ ] is it's a sphincter
right what about that muscle is weaker
and taller men then comparatively to
shorter man you're saying that they have
a weaker sphincter muscle that a bigger
muscle they have a bigger [ __ ]
yeah bigger muscle it would be tighter
not the other way around I'm really
confused about what point you're trying
to make but it's not compatible I know
it's probably not computing it's
probably not computing I don't as I talk
as I talk I realized that I don't really
know what I'm talking about but that
being said I threw it out there you know
because I'm you know I'm dreaming in
that way I'm whimsical in that way I
mean I just want to question things you
know but you went to a hundred percent
and now if you back down I'm gonna feel
crazy so don't back down explain to me
your logic George well it just
everything is bigger so if there's like
a small gap okay that's like saying a
rocket ship right when you close a
rocket ship because a rocket ship is so
big that the doors can't be as tightly
sealed rocket ships a man designed it
that way well you know if I design only
reason a rocket ship is like so tight is
cuz it has to be so tight if you have a
giant there poos are you can still have
a little bit of an opening his thing is
because tall people [ __ ] big that
they're there they're [ __ ] might
just be by virtue of big shits be looser
that's another question I have let me
throw this out there right it does right
a man who's six foot eight and weighs
300 pounds is this [ __ ] as large and as
a dwarf [ __ ] no well the equal ships no
that's the point I'm trying to make hey
sighs those your whole point no I'm just
saying that like let's suppose right
human beings we didn't have toilets and
we [ __ ] like you know out in the
wilderness yeah I'm out there I'm a
tracker right and I'm just walking
around and I see a piece of [ __ ] right
on the ground a human piece of [ __ ]
could I say to myself Wow
a guy with gigantism just shat [ __ ] here
or would I say well will they not know
the difference there we go that's
exactly the point I'm probably what is
the revelation you're trying to make is
I've had a revelation is that why you
nut so little Wow kalila on the [ __ ]
everytime no because you have always
said like I've never been with anyone as
short as you oh but I've also never been
with anyone but not so little so is
there a correlation between height and
the amount of jizz then no I'll give you
an example of my nut okay if you buy
order um whipped cream from the store it
comes in those canisters right sure and
if you press on it for three hours and
just let all the whipped cream come out
right and then you put it back in the
refrigerator that's what my [ __ ]
that's what it is used whipped already
you guys so when you do it nothing comes
out right so that's what my nut it has
nothing to do with my size hey guys this
came full circle I'm very proud of our
debates on his podcast so listen they're
whimsical questions that I have always
had walking down the street so tell me
about your father koala okay my dad is
220 pounds 6-8 Bobby
whimsical baby baby oh my god oh hey
guys we're take quick break to share
these amazing papayas with you hey y'all
I love Tiger belly fans but I also have
a special connection with our patreon